squish lib republican governor asa
hutchinson doubled down this week
on his argument that preventing perverts
from pumping little kids full of
cross-sex hormones
somehow violates a deep conservative
principle
i think it's helpful for our party to
have that kind of vigorous debate
about an important issue and uh to me
uh this is about the future of our party
are we gonna be a narrow party
uh that expresses ourself in intolerant
ways
are we going to be a broad-based party
that shows
conservative principles but also
compassion in dealing with some of the
most difficult issues that parents face
that individuals face
and at some point i had to say
i've got to remind my wonderful
republican colleagues that
we are the party of ronald reagan that
believes in a limited role of government
and let's just
ask that question sure i'm i sign
pro-life bills and i know that there's a
role for government even in the social
issues but we have to fundamentally ask
ourselves
do we need to do this is there a better
way is this something that we need to
leave to the hand
in the home or in the church our faith
leaders to handle
is this calling out for a government
solution do we need to pass
laws to protect little kids from being
pumped full of hormones by perverts do
we need
or can we just keep we'll just do it in
the home in the society
in the culture in other words politics
is downstream of culture how often have
we all heard that
how often have we all said that but does
asa hutchinson not realize
that culture can be downstream of
politics too i'm michael knowles this is
the michael knowles show
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome back to the show my favorite
comment yesterday from segan sagitta
who says i wish brian stelter would show
the same enthusiasm for voter id
that he shows for the vaccine passports
show me your id
or you cannot vote i know wouldn't that
be so great it kind of gives away the
game when you realize that the same
left-wingers who were saying that it's
racist and bigoted and outrageous and
terrible
to demand that people get id to vote are
demanding that people get id
to go into a bar or into a restaurant
things that affect their daily lives
multiple times a day
obviously the call for a covid passport
much more onerous than getting an id
just right before you go vote so you can
go and prove that you are who you say
you are but it's
not it's not about that at all this is
just about grabbing
political power not just cultural power
they have that we'll touch on that too
not just social power but political
power which republicans have been
ignoring for way
too long you know some of these social
cultural private companies
seem to be exercising a lot of political
power which is why you should protect
yourself and your identity with
expressvpn oh expressvpn
a few decades ago private citizens used
to enjoy
a lot of privacy what changed the
internet
having your private life exposed for
others to see was once something that
only celebrities worried about
but in an era where everyone is online
everyone has become a public figure
so to keep my data private when i go
online i turn to expressvpn
did you know that there are hundreds of
data brokers out there whose entire
business
is to buy and sell your data and the
worst part is they don't have to tell
you
who they're selling it to they don't
have to get your consent every time i
turn
expressvpn on i am given a random ip
address that is shared by other
expressvpn customers
that makes it much more difficult for
third parties to identify me
and harvest my data the best part is how
easy expressvpn is to use
no matter what device you're on phone
laptop smart tv
all you have to do you tap one button
you get protected
i used to think people weren't after my
data now i do not go online without it
if like me you believe that your data
ought to be your business
secure yourself with the number one
rated vpn on the market visit
expressvpn.com
michael and get three extra months for
free that is exp or essvpn.com
michael go to expressvpn.com michael
to learn more politics is downstream
of culture sure
yes what did andrew breitbart the patron
saint of hollywood conservatives what
did he mean when he said that
he meant that the entertainment industry
influences a lot of our political
discussion it's a
pretty straightforward point breitbart
put it in this
great memorable way but that's what he's
saying he's saying the entertainment
industry
affects a lot of our political thinking
so conservatives need to amass
and wield cultural power yeah
totally of course but does that mean
that policies that law that our
political institutions have no effect on
our culture that's just preposterous
i don't think that andrew breitbart
thought that first of all it's very
difficult to have a neat and tidy
distinction between politics and culture
to begin with
when our reality tv star former
president got elected
was he a cultural figure or a political
figure
when big technology companies that run
the social media
outside of the government when they
censor the duly elected president
are they are they behaving in a cultural
or a political way obviously
it's a little bit of both because both
culture and politics refers to
they both refer to how we all get along
together
does does culture get impacted by
politics yeah of course
look at east germany so right east
germany right now
is mostly atheist okay more than 50
percent of east germans are atheists
only 10 of west germans are atheist
does culture explain this is it because
of
regional variations in bratwurst that
you have a huge disparity in religiosity
no i think it it has to do with politics
i think it's because east germany was
dominated by the
officially atheist soviet union for
decades which pursued a ruthless policy
of stamping out christianity
and that had cultural effects even after
the east german government went away
even the most ardent disciples of the
breitbart doctrine on the right the ones
who say no government can never do
anything
we can never act through our political
institutions to affect what we want it's
only got to be cultural
because politics is downstream of
culture
if you ask those people hey do you think
the great society programs in the
60s affected the black family they will
all tell you yes of course it was
terrible
lyndon johnson and the great society
destroyed the black family okay well
that would seem to be an example of
culture being downstream of politics
breitbart made a very good point he's
right conservatives need to amass and
wield cultural power
but squish politicians are now
exploiting breitbart's argument
as an excuse for not doing their own
jobs in the political sphere
i didn't well i didn't elect asa
hutchins into everything but asa
hutchinson's constituents
didn't elect him to be the head of a
film studio or the pastor of a church
they elected him to be the governor so
he can do conservative things
and effect conservative policies and
he's just not doing it
fortunately some other states are taking
their roles seriously
montana and ohio are now in their
republican-led legislatures
placing restrictions on the ability of
people to obtain abortion pills through
the mail this is very good stuff
i'm very we we mentioned the first time
asa hutchinson brought up his ridiculous
reagan buckley point
the limited government point i said if
keeping kids from being castrated does
not fall within the
legitimate limits of government then
what does then the government is going
to be
the size of an atom right there's no the
limits are going to be so small nothing
fits inside it
here is another example of a good
mandate
of a good regulation of
a good time to outlaw something because
increasingly people can order abortion
pills
online they don't really even need to
consult a medical doctor
so right but that's not my primary
concern my primary concern here is that
babies are being killed
with with the tacit and sometimes
explicit approval of the law
but a secondary effect here is that
women are taking these drugs without
medical advice so could hurt them as
well
this is a good opportunity for the
government to step in
and say no you're not allowed to do that
but michael doesn't this constrict your
freedom no it certainly doesn't
constrict the baby's freedom but no
that's not
that's not what freedom is we've talked
about it a lot on this show
that liberty and licentiousness are not
the same thing they're actually polar
opposites
and it has been a trick of the left of
political correctness
to conflate the two things i talk about
this at great length
in my upcoming book speechless
controlling words controlling minds
available now
for pre-order you can also pre-order a
signed autographed first edition copy
just wanted to mention that just wanted
to throw that out there
they're not the same thing and even when
we discuss our
will our ability to pursue our will i
think we've got to get a little more
specific about this
i often use the example of the heroin
addict when the heroin addict
wants to go shoot up heroin and then a
bunch of squish
liberal politicians who sometimes
pretend they're republicans say oh yes
in the name of freedom we've got to let
the heroin addict shoot up heroin
is he pursuing his will kind of
but but not he's pursuing his lower will
he's pursuing his
appetite his desire he's not pursuing
his rational will we all know this right
saint paul writes about this where he
says the things i want to do i don't do
and the things i don't want to do
i do do what does that mean it means
that i've got certain passions
that rationally i know are bad and so it
the level of my intellect i don't want
to do them
but my flesh because we're all kind of
fleshy creatures my flesh does want to
do them and so i need to train my will
to stop my flesh from pursuing these
things
that is called liberal education that is
called
attaining liberty and virtue we all used
to know this in this country the
founding fathers wrote about it at
length
but we don't seem to get that anymore
because we've got this atrophied
shallow understanding of liberty
and culture and politics i give you
another example of the culture
the culture here that seems to act a lot
like
the political sphere like what mitch
mcconnell
has called a parallel government more
than 100
corporate leaders met over the weekend
to
plot out their opposition to voter
integrity laws across the united states
this includes this according to cbs news
leaders from american airlines
united airlines levi strauss walmart
viacom aerial investments linkedin
twitter amc movie theaters they're still
around i'm shocked
and others were invited to this
left-wing cultural
private sector event for some of the
most powerful entities in the united
states
publicly traded entities in a lot of
cases to
undermine our election integrity laws to
undermine our constitutional republic
should we just say okay well that's the
culture
throw our hands up we just need to write
better books or something
no of course not i am all for
don't get me wrong i am all for a
thriving
broadly protected private sector
where people broadly get to
[Music]
act without too much impediment from the
federal government
but there are limits here we're talking
about limited government
limited we're talking about true liberty
here
which has limits when these woke
companies
are putting their immense amount of
cultural
and political power they all got
lobbyists and they all these lines blur
together a lot
when they are putting that at the
service of undermining our
political system undermining the
will of the people of georgia through
their elected representatives
to pass some election integrity laws
which by the way
we had across this country before they
were weakened by the 2020 election in
some cases
explicitly violating state constitutions
to make it easier for democrats to get
votes
when those companies do that then i
don't think we should protect them i
don't think that we need to suck up to
big corporate america
like some misguided republicans have
done for the last 20 years
i think we need to wield cultural power
sure stop buying harry's razors if you
don't like how much they hate your guts
okay also we need to wield political
power
we need to take these tax breaks away
from delta like they get in georgia
we need to maybe take even more
aggressive measures
at the political level on some of these
companies i
do not want to be governed by a bunch of
woke lunatics in congress
but i am even less inclined to be
governed by a bunch of woke lunatics in
corporate america
going to need to really get down in the
nitty gritty and compare
all these different companies when you
want to compare a lot of different
companies you should check out
select quote man that was the greatest
segue i've ever done
select quote comparison shops up highly
rated companies including prudential
banner life and mutual of omaha and
others to find you the company with the
best rates for example
select quote could find a 35 year old
man a 500 000
policy for under 19 a month that is less
than a dollar a day cup of coffee
costs more than that costs a lot more
than that select quotes breakthrough
technology allows them to quickly match
you
with the best insurance company to find
your policy plus
quotes are free especially as a new
father i will tell you i'd put off these
sorts of things for a while
as a new father all i'm thinking is god
forbid something happens
i do not want to leave my family in a
lurch give yourself peace we have your
family peace of mind give yourself peace
of mind today
let select quote save you time and money
get your free quote at selectquote.com
today that is selectquote.com for your
free quote don't put off protecting your
family another day
selectquote.com get full details on the
example policy select quote.com
commercials your premium could vary
depending on your health issuing company
and other factors not available in all
states
corporate america colluding to undermine
our political process and our
constitutional order that is not good
however i do have some good news for
those who want to weaken
certain woke aspects of corporate
america at least one liberal corporation
is not doing very well that would be
good pillow
now good pillow it's not i guess it's
legally a company it isn't doing
anything yet
good pillow was the liberal
pillow company that david hogg the
the activist and some other guy whose
name i forget but i actually met him one
time but anyway
i forget him he's like a twitter
left-wing troll guy they came together
and they formed this pillow company and
they just talked they said this is so
great
we're gonna put mike lindell out of
business we're gonna we hate my pillow
it's too conservative
some of us called call to the new
liberal version of my pillow mao pillow
or our pillow is another one for the
real reds out there
but anyway it's collapsing so david hogg
tweets out quote
effective immediately i have resigned
and released all shares any ownership
and any control of goodpillow
llc i want to thank his partnership i
assume he's referring to this
guy whose name i forget and wish
absolutely nothing but success with the
future of good pillow
so he's resigning all of his shares and
it turns out i did the calculations
all of david hogg's shares of good
pillow
plus 29.98 will get you
one premium queen-sized my pillow which
is great that's good news for him
he finds the 29.98 this whole fiasco
is representative of david's
political affiliation and also
of his generation
they all want the semblance of the thing
but they don't want the thing itself
they all want the
adulation they want the nice write-ups
they want to be told they're doing great
work
they're they're brilliant they're
leading the country they're bringing us
out of our age of darkness
but they don't know anything
the fact that the left often
relies on young people not just even
young people as spokesmen but young
people
to go out and vote at college campuses
and they're always trying to lower the
voting age
the fact that they're relying on people
who by definition are more ignorant than
older people
more educated people shows you this they
don't
know very much they're just full of
passionate intensity and desire they
haven't cultivated their higher will and
their intellect
they've only exercised their lower wills
and their desires and their appetites
and they get really angry and really
wrathful and really impetuous but
sometimes it all goes down in flames
these young very young activists should
be in school
right guys like why is david trying to
start a pillow company right now when is
he
isn't he in college he should be doing
that that's a better i'm not saying
like i'm scolding him you need to go
back to class i'm just saying it's a
better use of his time
than whatever fake pillow company some
liberal activists are trying to use him
to start
these people should be in school but
one of the reasons that they're not i
suppose is that the quality of education
has plummeted in this country there's a
newly released video of a teacher from
the san marco
unified school district this is in
california you'll be shocked to hear
yelling at her students over distance
learning
and other issues this was this was
posted to facebook apparently it's a
common
occurrence take a listen to what your
children are being taught in the virtual
classroom
my question is in your case where is the
uh white student union because
because we need all right white student
union james
you get everything if your parent
wants to talk to me about their
profession
and their opinion on their profession i
would love to hear that
i know very little about anything else
in the world other than education
okay however
if your parent wants to come talk to me
about how i'm not doing a good enough
job in distance learning based on what
you
need as an individual
just dare them to come at me because i'm
so
sick to my stomach of parents
trying to tell educators how to do their
job i have never once gone to a doctor's
appointment
and tried to tell my medical health
provider how to treat me
you know why because i know nothing
about that i didn't get my degree
in medicine i know nothing about that i
know very little about
anything in the world that those are
true statements i would suspect
not the sort of thing you want to hear
your kid's teacher say look i know very
little about anything
in the world other than education
you see the problem right education
is an instrument to convey
all all that other knowledge you know
about everything in the world
to a student right you're supposed to
know a lot of things
like you know dates and battles
and the books instead you're supposed to
know all that
and then education is the process
by which you convey all of that
knowledge which this woman admits she
doesn't have
to a student which is why she doesn't do
it very well she also doesn't seem to be
particularly talented
at the education part of it right if
you're screaming at students
and you're parroting a typical left-wing
racialist line
that we need to have racial grievance
groups and racial unions
for every racial group except for white
people the awful terrible white people
and then to to make this point about
education that is so elementary but she
just doesn't understand it which is she
says
your parents have no role in your
education
i crazy ignorant lady i
am going to be your educator i who
haven't
cultivated my upper will and intellect i
who am given away to wrath
and invective i will educate you and how
dare your parents suggest they have any
say in it but of course
the family is the first place that
education happens
i'm not just talking about for
homeschoolers or people who have some
very solid view of the world
i'm saying for everybody the best
lessons you ever learned in your life
really the enduring lessons that you
learned maybe some
you learned in school i learned some
great lessons in school
but really those enduring lessons that
have really shaped my life
beyond even the technical aspects of
learning how to write learning how to
read history
the ones that really shape how you are
educated meaning the whole person the
way you are raised up where did you
learn those you learn those at home
of course and
parents ought to have some say in their
child's education
this was one of the premises of william
f buckley jr's famous book that launched
the post-war conservative movement
god and man at yale that parents
trustees
people outside of the education system
ought to exert power on that education
system
is that going to be a cultural power or
political power we're talking about a
public school here
so it would seem that you got it it's a
little bit of both isn't it
certainly whatever parents or are living
in this school district
ought to exert a lot of political power
to make sure
that their students aren't being
educated by people like this crazy lady
how are the teachers getting away with
it the teachers are getting away with
this sort of thing
because of of the lockdowns because
they're they're now they get to teach
from distance learning
and they have a lock on these kids
they've clearly gone a little bit
kookier than usual even and they're just
sitting in their homes saying and
spatting off on whatever they want
and dr fauci says absolutely no
end in sight eating and drinking
indoors in restaurants and bars is that
okay now
no it's still not okay for the simple
reason that the level of infection the
dynamics of infection
in the community are still really
disturbingly
high like just yesterday there were
close to
000 new infections and we've been
hanging around
60 70 75 000 so
if you're not vaccinated please get
vaccinated as soon as vaccine becomes
available to you
and if you are vaccinated please
remember
that you still have to be careful and
not get involved in
crowded situations particularly indoors
where people are not wearing masks
so you get the vaccine but
you can't change the lockdown behavior
at all
and i ca this is by the way this is a
little bit of a side point does it sound
like dr
fauci has been moderating his accent a
little bit
does it sound like he's maybe i'm just
crazy here it sound to me it sounds like
he's tamping down the accent
because when he's ordinarily on tv it's
you know well listen here you
i'm defenchy and but it's actually
sounds like he's
i don't know if i'm not saying he's
heard my impression of him okay
i'm not saying that i'm just i'm just
wondering i'm just asking questions okay
i've been asking questions about
coronavirus from the very beginning
and i've been asking questions
specifically about the wisdom of these
stupid lockdown policies
that i have been ignoring as best i
possibly can other than when i
occasionally have to fly on an airplane
and i
said from the very beginning they're not
going to let this up it's not two weeks
to slow the spread it's not a month it's
not two months it's going to just go on
until we take that power back from them
how are we going to take the power back
are we going to take the power back by
just walking into bars with our masks
off
in some cases maybe in some cases you
don't want to get the owners in trouble
okay that's cultural power or are we
going to exert political
power and mandate that
power hungry technocrats like dr fauci
should never be able to amass the kind
of power that they have
probably we need a little bit of both
now there is one cultural issue where i
think
you really can help yourself
that would be when you're shopping for
auto parts and the best place to do that
rockauto.com
rockauto.com always offers the lowest
prices possible rather than
changing prices based on a bunch of
gimmicks on so tuesday you know
it's 30 up and then wednesday it's 20
down no not at all it's always reliable
and they will always give you the best
prices all right why would you go into
the brick and mortar store
and spend up to twice as much for the
same parts if you need for instance this
is just off the top of my head
a delphi fg1456 fuel pump assembly for i
don't know let's say uh 2005 to 2010
honda odyssey and let's say costs
i'm spitballing 354 dollars at a big
chain store that's the sort of thing
rock auto will give you
for 217 bucks do not spend money
needlessly do not humiliate yourself by
going into that store
and not having answers to all those
questions they have rockauto.com
great family business the website is so
easy to navigate
even i can do it that is very impressive
go to rockauto.com right now see all the
parts available for your car or truck
then write nulls know w-l-e-s and their
how did you hear about xbox so that they
know
that we sent you also make sure that you
check out
ben shapiro's show because ben is going
to be talking about
the next riot in minneapolis you me and
the next riot
they just this probably when ben wrote
the show there was one riot
but there's a new riot for a completely
different reason right now also
it's already time for episode five of
candace people can't get enough of
candace owens you know that
if you have not checked it out yet what
are you waiting for the fearless candace
owens hosts a
lively series of guests each week for a
discussion panel interviews and her
signature
cancel corner and if you look closely
not even that closely you'll see a giant
picture of my head there
for that time that harry's tried to
cancel me this week
she'll be hosting comedian and podcaster
adam carolla tune in because you will
not want to miss their conversation the
show streams on fridays at 9 pm eastern
8 p.m central
at dailywire.com but you can get the
audio podcast candace
on apple spotify or wherever you listen
to your podcasts if you need
some candace owens in your podcast feed
look no further head on over to
apple podcasts or spotify and subscribe
today be sure to leave a five star
review if you like what you hear we will
be right back with a lot more
dr fauci is clearly attempting to
hold the lockdowns over everybody until
a sufficient number of people in his
estimation get vaccinated
that that's clearly the point right he's
sort of admitted this
he said well you know look the
percentages maybe i'll bump it up a
little bit bump it down a little bit
because we're just trying to get
sorry well look maybe we're going to
bump the percentages up a little bit
down a little bit but we're just trying
to get everybody
vaccinated that's that sort of thing i'm
paraphrasing him here but
by the way that is his job if you buy
into the
cult of public health you recognize
that the progressive vision here is we
will be governed by a panel of experts
who possess the science capital s
trademark over the e
and the political power public
politics science or health rather
science
so the political aspect here is that
fauci is trying to persuade people and
lead people to doing what he wants them
to do a lot of this involves getting the
vaccine
but they're having a little bit of
trouble getting the vaccine
gensake is focusing in her recent press
conference
on trouble getting evangelical
white voters to take the vaccine you
know that awful group of people worst
people in this whole country if you ask
me
jen saki is very upset that white image
alcohols won't get the vaccine and show
so she was asked how they're trying to
remedy this situation
and she has a simple answer they're just
going to start advertising on nascar
we're also investing 3 billion to states
and community community-based
organizations to
strengthen vaccine confidence in the
highest risk and hardest-hit
communities and often people think of
that as just black and brown communities
and that is not as you've noted that is
also
conservative communities white
evangelicals it's a range of communities
around the country
what we found to be most effective is to
work with these local organizations so
faith-based organizations community
health organizations
civic leaders and others who can really
get this message deeply
in communities we've also had a number
of our um
members of our covid team from dr fauci
and
uh fr and dr collins uh participate as
an example
participate in a range of media
interviews you know an example is dr
collins participated in the 700 club
dr nunez smith hosted a faith leaders
roundtable
uh we're also looking for we've run psas
on the deadliest catch
we're engaged with nascar and country
music tv we're looking for a range of
creative ways to
get directly connected to white
conservative communities we won't always
be the best
messengers but we're still trying to
meet people where they are
okay so she's putting this on with a
real sincere straight face she's saying
look we're just we're trying to reach
these white evangelicals
and she she ignores the fact that
similar rates of black americans are not
getting the vaccine
as white evangelical americans she's
kind of she's brushing that to the side
she's like these white evangelicals and
we're trying to reach out to them where
they are you know in their culture so
we're
we're advertising on uh the deadliest
catch
you know we're advertising on nascar
and so we're just doing our best this is
obviously a dig
at white conservatives she do you think
that she would say if she were to
address these similar rates
of reluctance to get the vaccine among
black people do you think she would say
you know we're trying to reach black
people by advertising in gangsta rap
and tyler perry movies and so we're just
but we're just trying to meet them where
they are no of course not
she not not by the way not because black
people don't listen to rap music and not
because white people don't watch
the deadliest catch or whatever or
nascar but because
the specificity here it would be
designed to create a caricature
and that's obviously what she's doing
here it's just it's a slightly subtle
dig
um so kudos to jensaki who is usually
rather unsubtle for
using a bit of subtlety but it's it's
creating a caricature
of culture the implication of course
that it's completely insane
for these white evangelicals to be
reluctant to get a vaccine or to make a
risk assessment over the vaccine
completely ridiculous
and we know better here in the biden
administration and we have the science
you know with the capital s and
everything so now we're going to
convince you to do it
maybe hear me out maybe these groups of
people the black americans who are
reluctant to get it
and the white evangelicals maybe they're
making a risk calculation
and they're saying well my risk depends
who you are if you're elderly or if
you're
fat then you might you might have a
greater risk
from covit itself but if you're let's
say you're relatively healthy you're
relatively thin you're relatively young
your risk from covid is pretty low and
you're saying okay well i just i'm not
saying the vaccine is
poisonous i'm not saying the vaccine is
going to kill me i'm not saying it's
going to pump me full of 4g
5g and make my telephone you know
service much better
or whatever other theories you're
reading on the internet i'm just saying
i don't
i don't really need it i think just this
morning didn't i read somewhere that one
of the vaccines is now being recalled
johnson and johnson vaccine i believe
because
it's causing a very small number of
people
but still enough people that they're
taking some steps here to deal with it
a blood clotting issue in women okay
well maybe that means that people have
some right to be a little bit skeptical
or a little reluctant
i'm not saying across the board i'm not
i'm not anti-vaxx
don't call me anti-vaxx i'm just saying
if i'm a healthy young guy why do i need
to worry about this well because dr
fauci told me to
and because i'm watching the deadliest
catch and they told me they told me to
in the commercials
as well those white evangelicals
those why those white people they drive
me crazy speaking of racial tensions
there is more rioting going on back
somehow
in minnesota why is this because of
a shooting an officer-involved shooting
of dante wright
who well i'll tell you what just take a
listen to the footage and you can see
what happened because it seems to be a
whole mess of a situation
so dante wright is this guy being
arrested
outside of his car they got him in the
cuffs and then he breaks away and he
jumps in his in his car he gets back in
his car he's resist
obviously resisting arrest who knows is
he reaching for some weapon or something
like that
he's trying to drive off now this woman
pulls her gun out screams taser
he drives off but you hear her say i
just shot him
so what happened
the woman didn't reach for her taser
maybe she thought she did she seemed to
think that she did
but she grabbed her pistol and then shot
this dude in the car
so it doesn't sound like she did it
intentionally
because she drives away and she says oh
my goodness oh my gosh what just
happened i shot him
also this guy was resisting arrest
he was being arrested for a weapons
charge
and uh and escaping police before he was
then killed
which is now sparking more blm race
rioting and looting
the criminal complaint says he had an
illegal ruger 45 pistol
and then he skipped his court date
do we need to totally defend this woman
cop
no i i it seems that she was
quite inapt here really regardless of
the weapons charge or skipping arrest
you should not be grabbing a pistol and
shooting a guy
when you think that it's a taser when
you right that doesn't
if she'd shot him with the taser i think
totally totally fine but that
that seems like a big big mistake and
when life and death is on the line you
can't
can't tolerate that also you shouldn't
resist arrest
and you shouldn't skip your court date
for your weapons charge
and cops who are under attack in this
country
have some right to arrest criminals
and to protect themselves when these
guys try to get away
horrible situation all around for
everybody involved
the guy should not have died at this
traffic stop at least
at least given what we know about this
traffic stop at the moment that he died
that should not have happened also if he
had not resisted a rest it would not
have happened
okay that's i think as reasonable a take
on the shooting as you can possibly have
so now minnesota is going up in flames
again
minneapolis mayor jacob frey frye has
declared a state of emergency in the
city
together with the saint paul mayor
melvin carter has announced a curfew
starting at 7 p.m
as the city braces for further riots
following
this shooting the national guard was
called out sunday night to help keep the
peace
and is likely to assist minneapolis and
brooklyn center law enforcement monday
night
if i were the mayor of minneapolis or
saint paul
nobody has elected me to that position
seems like a pretty blue place so
something tells me
i would not be elected there my solution
to this would be yup call in the
national guard
institute a curfew and then anybody who
riots
gets arrested and goes to prison for a
very long time
and then when you have arrested all of
these rioters
one you or even a good percentage of the
writers you
deter further rioting which
these feckless people did not do last
year when blm torched the city for the
first time in recent memory they didn't
do that so they encouraged more of this
violence but also when you when you put
enough of the riders in prison you don't
have any more rioters
now we are told we have an
over-incarceration problem in the united
states
as long as cities are being torched i
don't think we have an
over incarceration problem i think
as senator tom cotton pointed out the
other day we have an
under incarceration problem
because we got all these criminals who
are torching the cities
and burning people's private businesses
and private homes
it's the cultural side and burning
government buildings that's the
political side
and we're not just going to have a
cultural response and you know persuade
people through our local
civic organizations like the lions club
you can do that too that's helpful
and make better movies and have cultural
institutions yeah go ahead do that
also you need a political response from
the government the left doesn't want to
do that though the left doesn't really
want to tamp down the violence
that's why they've encouraged that's why
kamala harris last year
bailed these criminals out of prison she
raised money to bail the criminal
riders out of prison out of jail
they don't want to tamp this stuff down
because the left thrives on crises and
the other
strategy that the left relies on is the
redefinition of words bernie sanders
showing this
just the other day so this all began
because kirsten gillibrand the not very
successful
democrat candidate for president senator
from new york she tweeted out quote
paid leave is infrastructure child care
is infrastructure care giving is
infrastructure
now of course those sentences don't mean
anything because
none of them is true you could just say
you'd say like
apples apple is
love television
is up
purple is seven right you're i know
you're saying
words and they seem to they've got the
noun and the verb but they don't mean
anything
bernie sanders picking up on this theme
from kirsten gillibrand is also
radically redefining the word
infrastructure we've got to take a broad
look of what infrastructure means human
infrastructure
for ordinary people human infrastructure
means housing
you've got a half a million people in
this country who are homeless you've got
19 million
households who are spending 50 percent
of their limited incomes on housing
we need to build housing and by the way
when you deal
with housing you create jobs you've got
to deal with climate change who in their
right mind
would believe that transforming our
energy
system to protect us from the
devastation that we're seeing from
climate change
who would not believe that that is not
infrastructure
so moving away from fossil fuel to
energy efficiency and sustainable
energies that can create millions of
jobs
when i talk about infrastructure it
means if a worker mom and dad are going
to work
they have the right to know that their
kids are in decent child care that's
infrastructure
infrastructure is having the best
educated workforce in the world
child care is infrastructure education
is infrastructure but it isn't
infrastructure is infrastructure roads
and bridges that's what infrastructure
is education
is education child care is
child care but this is what the left
relies on
they believe that by redefining words
they can redefine reality this is
the central feature of political
correctness this is something that i
detail
at great length in my upcoming book
speechless controlling words controlling
minds available now
for pre-order you
see this on the left when it when i
guess the the way that you can always
tell they're about to do this
is when they say or imply when you
really think about it
right whenever whenever they say or
imply as bernie i think implied but
sometimes they say it explicitly
hey when you really think about it
isn't child care infrastructure whatever
they say when you really think about it
just
know there will not be any thinking
going on
you will have to suppress your thinking
your higher will and intellect
to become a gullible fool and go in for
whatever they're saying because
when you really think about it child
care is not infrastructure they're
different things
they can be good child care can be good
actually raising your own child can be
really good highly recommended
but sure certain education can be good
unless you're going to that unified
school district in san marco
with the crazy teachers but there can be
good education that can be bad sure
that's fine it just
isn't infrastructure and no amount of
bernie sanders or any other leftist
trying to redefine words is going to
make it
so the reason they're pushing this now
is because they're trying to push
through an infrastructure bill
infrastructure funding and so they want
to get all of their goodies into that
bill
just like how they put 91 percent of a
covid bill
they make 91 of a covet bill just about
whatever random nonsense they want they
say well when you really think about it
isn't socialized medicine isn't that
infrastructure
or in the covered case when you really
think about it isn't child care
public health and covid protection uh no
i don't when i really think about it i
don't think it is
the libs by the way are planning on
putting
some infrastructure in our bodies a lot
of talk about infrastructure now
they apparently want to put a little bit
of that in our bodies
this report just came out yesterday i'm
not joking i did not find this in the
deep recesses of the internet this is
being
published by the mainstream even
left-wing outlets
doctors and researchers at the pentagon
are working to prevent a future pandemic
by developing a microchip that can go
under our skin that can detect a virus
this according to dr matt hepburn a
retired army infectious disease
physician
this is part of the defense advanced
research projects agency or darpa
which is a secret research agency not
that secret because we're talking about
it on this show
tasked with protecting soldiers from
contagious diseases and biological
weapons
i can't believe i'm saying this for the
second time
in what a week or two but it it
seems like alex jones and associated
people
were sort of right i'm not saying
i want to be very clear i am not saying
that the government is currently
injecting people with microchips but
the news report is very clear they are
developing a microchip that can go under
a person's skin to detect diseases
the neck the headline that i'm going to
read tomorrow is going to be
breaking news pentagon confirms
that they are in fact turning the
frickin frogs gay that i wouldn't be
surprised
and by the way the epa and yale
university were
engaging in research on whether or not
chemicals in the water in connecticut
were turning the frickin frogs trans
not gay actually they were turning them
trans
this is on the one hand i want to i want
to
back away for a moment from all the
theories about the
microchips and stuff like that on the
one hand this is
incredibly technologically impressive
okay i'm gonna put the political
question aside for a second i'm just
focusing on the science or the
technology or whatever
it is very impressive that scientists
could develop a microchip
that can detect if you are coming down
with a virus and
you know beep or boop or something or
light up and tell you that you've got to
go
get some medical care that that is
that's genuinely very impressive
i don't want it don't want it not
interested
i don't care i am not
an adherent of the cult of public health
i know a lot of people are
at the cultural and the political level
that's how these sociopath politicians
and public health officials
have shut down our country for a year i
don't want it
if the option is
live 10 years longer with a microchip
under
under your skin that makes you neurotic
about
every time you're about to get a virus
or something in social distance and wear
the stupid masks and what
all that nonsense but you live 10 years
longer or
don't live 10 years longer but don't
live your life
in the neurotic paranoid fear of coming
down with the sniffles
and ultimately the neurotic fear of
death i'm gonna take the latter
because no one here gets out alive i'd
like to live a good
good long life emphasis on the good i
suppose but i know look eventually
if i am to have a future it ain't going
to be here because we're all
we're all going down eventually and and
hopefully that that natural fact helps
you to think about supernatural and
eternal things
or we can all just become neurotic
ninnies and put microchips in our skin
and worry about getting
the flu or whatever speaking of
outlandish things that have become
plausible
can't miss this story according to the
new york post
there is a new york parent who wants to
marry
his or her own child
we do not know whether this individual
is a man or a woman this parent because
the person who has filed this court
document
has wants to remain anonymous because
obviously this person is a sicko
and we also don't know the sex of the
child because in the last five or seven
years we've redefined
marriage fundamentally redefined
marriage to take sexual difference out
of it so we don't know is it a daughter
is it a son we don't know here's what we
do know
as a matter of quote individual autonomy
this parent wants to remain anonymous
because
what what he or she wants is quote an
action that a large segment of society
views is morally socially and
biologically repugnant
but what this person wants is quote
through the enduring bond of marriage
two persons whatever relationship they
might otherwise have with one another
can find a greater level of expression
intimacy and spirituality and therefore
this person wants to marry his or her
child
that language maybe intentionally so
is the language of anthony kennedy's
decision
in obergefell v hodges the decision that
redefined marriage from the court bench
to include monogamous same-sex unions
the question i i wonder if this is a
troll i wonder if this parent
suing to marry his or her own son or
daughter is is doing so to make a point
or maybe it's real though i mean this
sort of creepy stuff does happen a lot
in our culture
regardless the question i have is
by the logic of obergefell by the logic
according to which the supreme court
specifically anthony kennedy
redefined marriage to include monogamous
same-sex unions
why should this matter be any different
why should these people be excluded from
this important bond of marriage
why should these people's individual
autonomy
between consul consenting adults who by
the way can't procreate
it says in the court documents they
can't procreate so who knows maybe it's
an age thing maybe it's a sex thing who
knows
why should they be excluded for that
what's the argument
what's the argument well because it's
it's wrong well that's what you say but
you know that's just your opinion man
come on man
it's just your value system maybe people
have other value systems
isn't doesn't marriage expand intimacy
well anton scalia had a great line about
this which is he says you know anthony
kennedy says that
marriage expands intimacy but as someone
who's been in a long time marriage i
i think actually marriage uh restricts
rather than expands
intimacy ask the nearest hippie
which is a great line marriage expands
spirituality what does that mean i have
no idea
neither does kennedy neither does the
person writing this
but what's the limiting principle there
isn't one
so then maybe we need to rethink some of
the radicalism that we've
engaged in in the last few years not
because we hate people not even
first of all not because we hate
homosexuals
right no one's saying we we need to
outlaw homosexuals
no one's saying that at all but what the
left has done because they're so smart
about this
they conflate these two things they say
well if you don't want to radically
redefine the fundamental political
institution
and cultural institution by the way the
building block of society
the family if you don't want to
fundamentally redefine it from what it's
been for all of human history everywhere
on earth
then you hate gay people and you want to
ban them and you don't want to let them
do anything and you're you're mean what
what are you talking what are you
talking about
well what they're talking about is using
language
a topic i talk about at great length by
the way and speechless controlling words
controlling minds available now for
pre-order
using language to redefine these
cultural questions and these political
questions and then bullying you the
conservative tricking you the
conservative
into only focusing on the cultural
matters where by the way
they're not the le the right is not
wielding power anyway
and totally conceding the political
realm
seems like a big trick seems like we
should wake up to it and start fighting
back i'm michael knowles is the michael
and i'll show you tomorrow
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer
jeremy boary our technical director is
austin stevens
supervising producers mathis glover and
robert sterling
production manager pavel vadovsky editor
and associate producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator mckenna waters
the michael knowles show is a daily wire
production copyright daily wire
2021 today on the ben shapiro show
another police shooting of an unarmed
black man in minneapolis spurs riots
proceeded to leave calls for an end to
policing
and the federal government puts a pause
on the johnson and johnson vaccine for
no apparent reason that's today on the
ben shapiro show give it a listen